Thanks everyone, for being here.
My name is Mike Prysner.
I'm a co-founder of an organization of soldiers,...
...active duty soldiers and veterans called March Forward...
...and I'm also a former member of the US army...
...and deployed to Iraq in March of 2003 as a part of the initial invasion...
...when I was 19 years old.
And I think the pictures we saw moments ago...
...kind of speak for me, going to Iraq in 2003,...
...believing what I was told that we're going to help the Iraqi people...
...to bring them a better life, to defend our friends and family back at home.
It took 12 months occupying that country,...
...of seeing young children crying hysterically as we ripped them from their homes,...
...of seeing a man shot through the neck,...
...brought to a prison cell instead of being brought to a hospital,...
...seeing men sob uncontrollably and...
...urinate themselves in detention facilities during interrogation.
All of that pain and suffering...
...made me see that there is no way in hell that this was a war of liberation.
This was something else.
And what I was a part of was defined at the Nuremberg trials...
...as the most supreme crime against humanity.
And that's the illegal war of aggression against a sovereign nation.